you give this kind of like your map and
I'm gonna teach you to read the map
today
okay sorry I think the first thing we'll
do is umm I can I get this off the
screen now can I can I take it down
because you can be birth wards where
we're gonna start is just this first bit
it starts off nice and gentle mark 1
part 1 the first thing I wanna do is to
say take that 9 all it's not the
projector off in one second where you
look at this guy oops and we want to
know the coefficient of x to the power
of 2 n that's what we're looking for
okay so have a look this is very simple
to just like stock standard binomial
theorem okay so if I consider this from
with a quickest way to get to this is
the same but the general term and by the
way I like to say the phrase general
term before I write T okay because as
you see sometimes textbooks will be T of
K is the term other than your little T
is the code I just think it to be
confusing so just term say um I would
not I don't think that systemness like
I've never seen I've never seen that
acronym Emma so I don't think it's like
a recognizable all over for us and I'll
take you second what I'm working out is
each one of these terms is in exactly
the same for that so what is the cape
term going to be
okay so I'll give you a clue it's not
fit that okay so there are going to be
like its which row of Pascal's triangle
Mir and the answer is up on the 14th row
aisle 4 and choose whichever term along
your goal and then you're gonna have
some number of these and some number of
these okay so which one would you like
me to have as the K term and which one
you'd like maybe for you - there okay so
I'll go
okay which means there are going to be
this many what the terms have you not
okay how's that look that's a shelter
so therefore what they want is the
coefficient of the X to the 2n right so
therefore I could say c2 n is going to
be there is the desired power of X that
I was after and that's how many wants I
will have okay so there we go I've got
the bits that I need you can see that
these are going to be inconsequential
they just want the coefficients I can
see in there for the coefficient is this
okay so there we go that was the third
part eyes back to the question part one
is over part two is where it starts to
look worse but hold on to it I'm gonna
write this down a second by this one
should really with me they say show that
and they've got a new seemingly
unrelated expansion over there on the
left and then this weeds Sigma notation
thing on the right okay so that's what
we want to show before I get to that
before I get to that I noticed Syria yes
yes so you're already starting I hope to
see this this is the reason why it's a
part 1 part 2 part 3 think when I have a
look at this in fact I'm going to write
it down and maybe you want to do it as
well box review what am i required to
prove you've got this thing here 1 plus
x squared plus 2 X to the power 2 n and
then you've got this Sigma notation on
the right hand side so guys K right
yep okay good now I'm very very pleased
that some of you have noticed hey hey
hey this inside the brackets it's 1 plus
X all squared 1 plus X or square and if
there's a 2 up there then that 2 and the
2n are going to become 4m right so
immediately you have a clue I can't
there's gonna be a connection here good
fine little way though because have a
look at what they're asking you to do
over here right do you see that this
expansion is from 0 to 2 m right so they
don't want you to change this to a 4 n
just yet
they still want you to think about this
as there are going to be 2 n plus 1
terms so if you leave that power as what
it is the second thing I notice has two
hands to it number one um you notice
that there was 1 plus X or square
however it's written in a weed order
it's really a weird order look at this
who writes quadratics like this who
writes the x squared term in the middle
it's kind of weird okay that's the first
thing I notice the second thing I notice
is what is this about this is I'm not
used to having multiple X terms in there
like this should be 1 X term and then
there should be whatever the other term
is like a constant right so there's an X
and there's an X plus 2 now I'm pointing
both of these things out because there
are two sides of the same coin the X in
the X plus 2 come from that right there
do you see that you see that's x times X
plus 2 that's really x times X plus 2
okay so even though we've first noted
okay there's a clear connection between
this guy and this guy and I'm not going
to use that jasja keep it asleep we are
going to use it the bigger connection
between these two things is that I've
got to tease this out here does that
make sense okay so here's what I'm going
to do I'm going to say 1 plus x squared
plus 2x to the power of 2 in this is my
left hand side right I should say no but
let you inside how am I going to rewrite
it so that I can get to here yep
okay fantastic
so this is my new binomial that's a lot
of binomial
it's a tritone it's got three things but
having put these together it's like that
whole product there we go there's my 1
plus something to some power is that
right
and essentially I'm going to figure just
like I did before I'm just going to
state what this is going to be as the
binomial theorem tells me right so this
is the sum of from K equals not 2 to n
ok pause for a second do you remember
five six lines ago come in thank you
I asked you okay I'm about to write the
general term and the general term of
course this is the thing that you're
adding up in your secret notation okay
and I said to you well which one should
be the X and which one should be the one
now you because I've trained you to do
it chose the one to have the messy we
don't our of it because then it
simplifies out and it's nice and easy
right
but watch what happens if I do that here
okay if for instance I say okay I want
there to be the X X plus two I want them
to understand what I want there to be
two out of those sorry K of those which
means that I have two n minus K of those
yeah now that won't be nice and simple
it's just not what I want right because
look back back this is the result trying
to prove and for some reason that is not
clear to me yes they have chosen to put
the messy power on the X terms okay so
this is not going to get me to the
result I want so I'm going to abandon
that there huh good morning that's why I
asked you not to write this now instead
of making that the K powers going up I'm
going to make this the two n minus K
because that's where I can see they want
me to go so I'm gonna like that to n
minus K times okay cuz of course don't
skip that is it proof right it's not
trivial
and now pretty much I'm there do you see
I'm pretty much there I can write this
down because it's X to the power of
minus K and then there's an X plus 2 to
the power of 2 and low static okay say
yeah oh I just wanna take it Cabaye yeah
I just figured to write it here because
it's such an easy thing to forget to
write
okay been up better yep
okay so therefore your final line will
be 1 plus x squared plus 2x to the power
of 2 N equals and I'm just going to
write the rizona has required but this
time I'll write it properly with the
binomial coefficient in it yes okay I'm
done you're happy that's part two